Did you know that there are two Pirates of
the Caribbean scripts currently in development?
So, could Jack Sparrow fans see Johnny Depp
reprise his iconic role, now that his defamation
trial against ex-wife Amber Heard is over?
The answer may surprise you.
Finally, after more than a month of deliberation,
the jury hearing Johnny Depp and Amber Heard's
competing defamation lawsuits has reached
a verdict.
To briefly recap, Heard and Depp were married
from 2015 to 2017, and Heard alleges that
Depp was abusive to her during this time.
In 2018, Heard identified herself as a "public
figure representing domestic abuse" in an
essay for The Washington Post.
Depp characterized the allegations as a hoax
and claimed that Heard had been the one abusing
him.
"I can't say that I'm embarrassed because
I know that I'm doing the right thing."
Depp then claimed that the allegation caused
him to lose out on lucrative acting roles.
In late 2018, Depp sued Heard in Virginia
for defamation, seeking $50 million in damages.
The impact on Depp's career is central to
his lawsuit.
Under questioning from his own lawyer, Depp
claimed that Disney dropped him from the Pirates
of the Caribbean franchise after Heard's essay
was published.
Heard responded with a countersuit over Depp's
hoax allegations, claiming that Depp orchestrated
a campaign to get her fired from Aquaman and
from her job as a L'oréal spokesperson.
Depp already lost a similar defamation lawsuit
in the United Kingdom in November 2020, and
an appeal over that decision the following
March.
However, on June 1, 2022, the American jury
sided with Depp on all three counts of defamation,
awarding him $15 million in compensatory and
punitive damages.
The jury also upheld one of Heard's claims
of defamation, awarding her $2 million in
compensatory damages.
Now that the verdict is in, here's how it
could affect Depp's role in the Pirates of
the Caribbean franchise going forward.
"Captain, captain Jack Sparrow."
Currently, there are two Pirates of the Caribbean
scripts in development, which would make the
sixth and seventh installments in the franchise.
Producer Jerry Bruckheimer spoke about Johnny
Depp's future as Jack Sparrow weeks before
the verdict was reached.
When asked if Disney was planning to cast
Depp in the sixth film, Bruckheimer responded,
"Not at this point."
As it turns out, though, there might not be
a need for Depp in Pirates of the Caribbean
6 anyway.
Bruckheimer also revealed that the script
is centered on a female lead, with Margot
Robbie in mind.
That would seem to eliminate the need for
Jack Sparrow to factor into the story.
On the other hand, the seventh film isn't
centered around Robbie's possible character,
which could leave room for Jack Sparrow to
return in some capacity.
Bruckheimer added that "the future is yet
to be decided."
So, Bruckheimer was already leaving the door
open for a possible Depp return before the
verdict was reached.
Script specifics aside, the biggest question
is whether Disney wants to work with Depp
again or not.
The trial has undoubtedly tarnished Depp's
reputation.
Still, Bruckheimer's comments don't explicitly
rule out Depp's potential return.
Therefore, there's no guarantee Depp will
ever play Jack Sparrow again, but it sounds
like it hasn't been ruled out.
At the same time, it's important to consider
that Disney is only half of the equation.
Johnny Depp may not even want to come back
as Jack Sparrow after all that he's gone through
and how his relationship with the Walt Disney
Company has shifted in recent years.
In fact, during the trial, Depp confirmed
previous testimony that his connection with
the company has changed so drastically that
he wouldn't return to the role no matter how
much Disney offered.
"Nothing on this earth would get you to go
back and work with Disney on a 'Pirates of
the Caribbean' film.
Correct?"
"That is true Mr. Rottenborn."
The actor explained during his trial testimony:
"There was a deep and distinct sense of feeling
betrayed by the people that I've worked hard
for.
People that I delivered a character to that
they initially despised, but I stuck to my
guns with the character, and it seemed to
work."
While this could be pure hyperbole, considering
the circumstances, Depp's likely serious for
the time being.
Time will tell when the next Pirates of the
Caribbean project will sail into theaters,
but as things stand at the time of the Johnny
Depp-Amber Heard verdict, don't expect to
see Captain Jack Sparrow back in action when
it does.
If you or someone you know is dealing with
domestic abuse, you can call the National
Domestic Violence Hotline at 1−800−799−7233.
You can also find more information, resources,
and support at their website.